okay so uh
before we start i'll just uh talk a
little bit about
you know the the nature of the
presentation and the live coding
exercise here
so um
who's experienced haskell the first
thing you might see is uh
maybe some terms that are borrowed from
from mathematics um
you might see you know things that seem
a little bit different than
than the program that we use the
programming that we're used to
and that's okay at the end of the day
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to put together an application
at the end of the day what we're trying
to do is is put together an application
that's maintainable
we want maintainable software and that's
what we're trying to
achieve with haskell now haskell is not
just
well while haskell is just a programming
language languages actually influence
culture and so the culture of a haskell
project is
usually a little bit different than the
culture of some projects that that you
might have been on
um haskell is purely functional so
you'll see that haskell programmers
usually reach for purely functional
tools
you'll see that we try to do things in
terms of transformation rather than
than modification or in-place
modification and
these are the kind of things that you
know i'm going to try to push on
this in this tiny presentation
and during the live coding exercises so
if you want to follow along with the
live coding exercise
you'll probably need your hassle
compiler fired up
you'll probably need a uh a version of
cabal greater than 1.18
so you have sandboxes and some other
features and that's pretty much it
so how about we jump right into it
is there a reason for those gloves that
need to be like
really rough and tough i mean i code so
much
so
so i kind of went over this but let's
talk about the point
this isn't like the the the this is at
the beginning
of uh you know the the structure and
interpretation of computer programs
you know what it's basically saying is
that there's a lot of ways that we could
actually present programming language to
somebody
there's a ways that we can present
programming to people
uh for instance we could uh present
clever algorithms to make
you know programs run faster we can
explore the mathematical foundations of
programming and what
you know we can do to make programs
theoretically correct but you know what
what this
what the authors chose to focus on is
pretty much the techniques used to
control intellectual complexity of large
software systems
so we we really want to we really want
to focus and select tools and techniques
that help us reduce the the complexity
of software
because software can get very complex as
we all know
so i actually kind of simplify
all things because this is my diagram of
all things
all things kind of boil down to
communication and verification
in fact we could even make it simpler
all things boil down to communication
i just kind of you know annexed on
verification because when we communicate
we're doing a lot of verification
basically when i communicate to somebody
they kind of like go over in their mind
of what i
if what i said is actually kind of true
or has any relevance to them
and then they choose to or choose not to
communicate back
and that cycle goes on and on and on and
this is the kind of cycle that's the key
to
developing software and this is the
cycle that happens
on a very on pretty much every level of
a product's
product development so this is kind of
like a fractal in nature it actually
from the smallest you know element to
the largest element it's pretty much
that concept pretty much remains intact
so that pretty much boils down to
to feedback you know communication is
usually that communication
can be looked at as feedback so this is
a basic feedback loop
the classic feedback loop includes
action evidence relevance and
consequence
that's that's pretty much the classical
feedback loop but
that feedback loop really doesn't kind
of
embody what i'm trying to speak about
here
so you know when we say action we mean
someone's going to take action when we
say evidence we usually mean that you
know you get some evidence as to
whether your action actually affected
toward the world you see if that
that that of change in the world was
relevant to you
you think about the consequences of that
change
and you begin again now there's
something wrong with this feedback loop
and that
what's wrong with it it starts with an
action we can really never start with an
action
uh so i may come back to this but this
is
sort of the wrong feedback loop and many
projects in many
paradigms and languages take this sort
of attitude
but that's kind of not the attitude we
really want we want a different type of
attitude and this is called the oodaloo
little by general john boyd united
states military
so our feedback loop or the one that
we're going to consider for
this this presentation is the observe
orient decide
and act feedback loop
so given this new feedback loop of
observe
orient decide and act feedback loop
uh how does this to relate to the tools
that we're looking for in programming
well the tools and technique we're
looking for the tools and techniques
that facilitate communication and thus
increase the feedback needed to control
construct high quality software
rapidly so we want tools
that sort of embody that feedback loop
we want tools that give us the ability
to observe what's going on we always
need to know what's going on
we need to orient ourselves based on
what what we observe to be going on
we need to decide what to do next and we
need to act on that
and any tool that gives us that ability
or any tool that furthers that ability
or
augments that ability in a software
project are tools that we're looking for
so the tool that i'm going to choose is
is haskell and that's the tool that
we're going to be talking about today
again haskell is a language haskell
offers us that feedback loop that we
want
and as a language it dictates the
culture
it pretty much dictates the culture of
our pretty much a software project
all right does anybody recognize this
circuit
what kind of circuit is this
well that's right so it's an xor and an
n
if you combine an x or an n in this
fashion what you get is
called a half adder so a half adder can
take two bits
and it can add them together now of
course if you have two bits and they're
both one it's going to overflow
and that's where the k and so you get a
carryout so what we're going to do is
that we're actually going to use haskell
to construct this this circuit now this
should be a really
you know easy exercise and i'm hoping
that everyone
everyone can follow without without uh
without me introducing too much overhead
now the things that are
i'll explain the things that i want to
get out of this little exercise
as i go along so
let's see
yeah first i i need to expand this font
and i also need to like
actually get a view of my mini buffer
here because i don't have it
all right
yeah my virtual box is going insane
so give me a second to fix this virtual
box
okay let's see
all right i really don't know
how does that look is that the right
resolution
yeah it looks about right all right
so i've got this little project set up
here
and i've got my main module so this will
give me the perfect opportunity to
explain a little bit about haskell in
high school
forgive me
let's see let's boost all the way up to
like
18.
does that work a little bigger
i picked 18 last time i think i could
probably get away with
maybe 26.
oh yeah that's good
all right so so
as i go through this please keep in mind
the whole like feedback loop and
everything that we uh we had you know
just went over a little bit
prior so a high school program always
starts out
with a main function
that main function doesn't actually
return anything in this case
so we're really not sure what we're
going to do
with that main function so we'll leave
it undefined
at this point i typed in a little bit of
code a very small piece of code
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
actually try to see if that code is
without error so there's this vb
box hanging away showing telling me that
i need to get rid of it
whatever okay yes
cool
so when i evaluate this it says okay and
also i don't see any red underlining
here so i know everything is okay
so one of the things i can do is i can
go back and look at my half adder now
let's talk
let's talk about this half adder for a
second the thing that the half adder is
doing is it's taking two bits
it's adding those two bits together it's
giving you one bit that represents the
sum
and another bit that uh um represents
the carry
so we're not you know kind of adding
decimal otherwise
we'd carry on the 10 but we're actually
carrying on the binary place here
so two bits will carry if they're both
one
so
let's make a function without you know
kind of beating around the bush here
we'll make a function called
adder and an adder is going to take two
bits
and as the diagram explains it's going
to return
two more bits one representing the sum
and one representing
the the carry out one way we could
easily represent that in the haskell
program is by
putting two bits in there
okay so
all right so we give that to our
you know our sort of evaluator here and
our evaluator immediately comes back and
screams at us and says there's no such
thing as a bit
and that's fine that's okay that's
exactly what we wanted it to say
we want that incremental approach so we
start with our high level language we
say
you know this is a bit i want to use a
bit but there's no such thing as a bit
now we really didn't there was real
really no high ceremony or
a lot of overhead in describing trying
to say what a bit is
um or or using the term bit and we got
automatically got
back feedback on the level it pretty
much says there's no such thing as a bit
go back tell me what a bit is and try
again so what we're going to do is we're
going to go back and tell it what a bit
is
so yeah
no please um this isn't a bit of part
before the horse
in the sense that we're using for the um
for
um we're defining something that we
don't even know what the essence
of it is ah so i
so evie's question was was are we trying
are we kind of defining something before
we actually are we trying to use
something before we actually know what
it is and the answer is yes
and actually um this isn't the first
time that
we've visited this before uh i mean this
because
this is the whole premise of uh of test
driven development right
where we actually write a test before we
act before we have any kind of
implementation of that test
so if this was a if this was a
traditional test driven development i'd
be using bit before i actually
have have a any concept of what a bit is
i just know i need a bit
and then the test would come back and
say there's no such thing as a bit
prompting me to go and develop it but
how do you know you need
a day
good question
because we know about the domain so this
picture tells us that we need two bits
so we're trying to encode that in our
program so
let's go ahead and define a bit so
there's only two states that a bit has
and that's high
and low some people would say zero and
one one but i'll take
you know a more low level approach and
say that it's a high signal or a low
signal
usually in digital circuits is about
five volts and then low is about like
what one volt or something like that
sometimes highest well that would be
incorrect
yeah yeah
two constructors and one of the
constructors is the symbol high and the
other constructor is the symbol low
okay so you know
so
and we knew bit that we knew bit was a
type to begin with because we used it in
the
type signature
right but but it was in it was in the
place of a type
uh the type signature right
so we know we know from that that clue
that we intended it to be a type
so it looks like everything's okay so we
have
uh incrementally we have created a
function that's intended to
represent our half adder and we have our
our dependency now
which is the bit because we can't really
talk about a half adder unless we have a
bit
uh yes sir
so a bit is defined in terms of a high
signal and a low signal
and we say when we construct a bit the
value of of something of type bit could
either be high or low
uh in this case we can think about bit
being the type
and we can say that type can be
inhabited by two values one high
and one low so it could either be the
bit could either be high or low
but you don't have to define it further
but you can i could define it further
but that's the
so yeah you i could extend it yes
the only things that the only values
that can be of type bit are high and low
if i would have a if for example if i
had interior
in could be 0 1 all the way up to you
know until the
the computer can't fit it anymore so
that's kind of the analogy so now we
have a bit and high and low
so a half adder takes two bits either
either both of them are going to either
be high or low and returns a pair of two
bits one representing the sum
and one representing the carry out
so now that we have everything in place
we can go ahead and define this
so i'm going to move this down a little
bit to give a little bit more of a
viewing area
so
uh i believe in descriptive naming so
i'm not just going to say
you know a and b like the picture i'm
going to descriptively call these input
and input 2.
i'm telling you if i put a and b then
everyone else who
contributes to this program are going to
be using a's and b's and everything like
that
next thing you know you're going to have
an unreadable program that no one can
follow because the names are not
explicit so
single letter identifiers in haskell are
a big i'd say a problem
but sometimes the haskell programmers
are not trying to describe
how can i say the haskell programmers
are really not trying to describe
something that's concrete what they're
really trying to describe as a pattern
so when you see single letter
identifiers you're it's sort of a signal
in haskell that you should probably be
looking for the pattern
and the pattern is clear if the the
identifiers are
are kind of tiny and usually it's
representing something abstract so
giving it a descriptive name is really
not going to help very much
this is something that come up in other
programming paragraphs also
but my question is with inside a
function
would you say that you have to
semantically name all of the units
within the function or is it
do you think it's acceptable to um
default to
your classic haskell um
a's and b's x's and xs's
within a function i don't mean
externally but certainly within a
function
so i'll give an example um let's say
let's say i'm trying to describe a list
for example
now a list is actually a an abstract
concept if i want to describe the head
of a list then i would call it x
which is a sort of a convention in
haskell if i want to describe the tail
of a list i can call it x's which is
excess right now there's really no
descriptive name i can give that
because we're only this this function is
an operator on list
so all i can do is say okay i'll denote
the head of the list by x
so a lot of times you'll see like um
really general patterns in haskell on
list
on things that are even more general
than lists and yes they're going to have
these
these really uh you know generic names
because
the concept is is so generic that really
you can only assign a symbol to
some of the concepts that's right
however
when uh when you're working in a
high-level domain like this
i'm clearly talking about input one and
input two and i want to name it
according to that
and in fact i want to naven in such a
way that everyone who
who comes along and talks about it later
will also say input one and input two
and i try to do that now as for the
inside of a function
i would uh i would probably continue to
name it just as descriptively
the reason why is because when someone
reads this this uh this function they're
gonna need it and you'll
you'll be surprised how certain how just
abbreviating just a little bit
can cause confusion so one of the things
that we want to do here and i'm going to
talk about later in
the presentation is a programming
language as in you know the the
structure and interpretation of computer
programming thing when you program
you're actually programming for two
things
you're programming for another human and
you're programming for the machine
but really you're programming for
another human because the the program is
not just that static snapshot it's the
evolving
project and so really the computer is
gonna
i mean a human is gonna read it many
many times and write it only once so you
should
optimize for reading um
how can i say okay so now we have uh
input one and input two
so what we're going to do with this
input too uh is we're gonna actually
what we're going to do with this input
is we're actually going to
to describe the output so
the output is obviously a pair so we
build a pair
much like you know we would think we
would build a pair
and see it says that the first input is
actually the xor of the second
and uh is actually the xor of the second
input
or is xor with the the second input so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to say
input 1
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
xor it with input
2.
all right and it says that the second
one is and
is the end of a and b so i can say input
one and i'll just give it a little bit
of an
end here and i'll say input
two right
so automatically we can see something's
wrong because the the compiler is kind
of screaming at me here and let's see
what the information it gives me
it says there's no such thing as xor and
that's wonderful um
because i haven't implemented it yet but
i know it should go there
so once i implement xor i could actually
i expect that error to go away so as you
can see the type system is providing a
lot of benefits
a lot of the same a lot of the same
benefits that type
test driven development would offer us
so what is
ah okay so i i actually cheated and did
a mouse over
and i got it however what what you can
do is uh
is you could obviously just evaluate it
and it'll say not in scope xor
okay
the fact that it's underlined is yelling
at me telling some telling me
something's wrong that's how i knew to
to uh to go ahead and and
mouse over
that is the emax mode of um uh
that's the haskell mode for emacs yes
connected to the passport compiler
in a sense yeah okay
so i'm gonna have to define xor
okay and i'm gonna have to define it in
terms of bits so basically xor
simply takes a bit uh two bits
and what it does is give back a third
bit
so that's what xor does and what we can
do with xor is we can say that
if xor means that if they're both
different then it's hot
otherwise it's uh it's it's not
so what i can say i mean i could do it
strictly by pattern matching or i can
say
well let's do it strictly by pattern
matching so people can see
so if i get a high and a low then we
know that the output is going to be
high right and if i get a low
a low and a high then we know that the
output is also going to be high
because xor is to find that if they're
both different than then everything's
good
however if we get anything else
then we know the output is going to be
low
and so it looks like the compiler likes
our definition so since the compiler
likes our definition we expect the
the the error to change
let's see what it actually said
okay
oh okay so right now it's telling us
that it
it it doesn't like end so end it happens
to already be defined
and happens to be defined in prelude so
it's clashing with our
m so whenever you have a name clash in
haskell
you just import for instance hey
um
i'm just going to go ahead and hide the
definition that's clashing with our
definition
so i i had the definition now i should
actually have a
an error that's relevant to what we're
saying okay so it says not in scope end
and that's what we're
we're actually looking for so that means
i'm expecting that once i i define and i
should actually have my
my half adder working so
and takes a bit and another bit
sorry and it takes
it's another bit and of course and
is and only has one case of course and
that's when
they're both high when they're both high
it's high
and end any other case
is obviously going to be low so now we
have
everything defined and let's see what
kind of errors we're getting there
we get no errors here so it looks like
the
the compiler really liked what we were
what we're talking about now
the compiler or the type checker for
instance is coming back and saying what
you just said to me actually makes sense
and since we're talking in our very high
level language
like for instance we don't see i mean it
may not be fair because we're not doing
any looping or any other kind of stuff
like that
but we really don't have any uh any
anything here other than some
some syntax for the the compiler and
um and pretty much our domain terms so
when we're talking about a half adder
we're talking about a half adder we're
talking about xor we're talking about
and
and we're talking about bits and so as
you can see our program consists of
mostly that
and some added syntax to for to
appease haskell and that's kind of what
we want
so if you ever heard of a concept called
domain driven design
you know the domain driven design is
very heavy on developing
you know like a domain language like for
instance if i say a half adder
that should be a domain term like if if
you know
the the electrical engineer comes up to
me and says you know
make me a half adder and simulate a half
adder well
what i should be talking about in my
program is a half adder
so that when i talk to the electrical
engineer he knows what a half adder is
when another programmer comes onto the
team he knows what a half adder is
if i call it h a he may not know that
it's a half adder
somewhere along this along the line
another another concept is what the
initials h a is going to come in
and there's going to be some ambiguity
so we can i mean we can already see the
value of explicitly writing things we
could already see the value of a domain
language we could already see the value
of purity
because look how my program does not
work with any side effects
but let's check the program and see if
it actually works because there might be
an error in the program
there might be an error in the program
because this is um
i just kind of wrote this program right
now so
if i take a half adder and i give it a
zero and a one
for instance if i give it a high and a
low
then i expect the sum to be one and i
expect there to be no carryout
so oh the program does not work
and why because it has no way of knowing
how to show a bit
so let's see how we'll fix that
all right okay now we have a way of
showing
a bit um
all right so let's do a half add adder
and let's give it a high and a low
and so you know if we give a half hour
high and low well the sum of
zero and one is of course just one so
you know the half had a return to hide
saying that the sum is one and it says
that the carryout is low because there
is no
there is no carry out because it's one
and it can it can sufficiently represent
that
with its some bit if of course we uh
tried again
and gave it a low
a low and a high it'll give us the same
thing
if we tried it again and gave it two
highs
we expect the k we expect the sum to be
low and we expect the carryout to be
high
because we just carried over to the
additional to the the
additional bit which gives us obviously
two because one and one is two so that
ends up
carrying over to the next place so as
you can see that's our
our are half adder
so that's the definition of a half
header again uh i want to stress that
we're using high level terms and so
forth and so on
so without is there any questions with
that
before i go ahead and quotes around
good question okay so and uh haskell
uh runs in the default hat and default
haskell there's
uh the the functions are usually prefix
functions
they're not infix so if i want to make a
function and turn it into sort of like
an infix operator
i can use these quotes and i can do that
with any function
uh if it has more than two variables
then it's just going to go after the
second variable
so that's how you would actually use it
and is that right evie
is it tested
all right whatever i'll i'll find that
out put that out later
that eludes me so preference for intex
as opposed to prefix
well i mean i i certainly do like uh
um i certainly do like you know
infix operators when there's only two
but when there's
thank you evie you've answered your own
questions
that's cool i mean if we have a like
like for instance if we have like
multi-valued ends
uh we could like you know um
like prelude it has the end to find on
bulls
and if we just look at some information
for that we can see that what it does is
it takes a list of booleans
so therefore like when we have
multi-valued ends we just kind of
give it a list of events that's right
so um so uh end actually happens to be
multi-valued end actually ends up being
a unary like
function so let's let's uh move on
because
there's a the next portion actually
drives home another point
now does anybody recognize this circuit
this circuit is a full adder now
if we look at the if we look at a full
adder we actually have uh
well i could recognize two half adders
in there
so i can see one half adder here
like you know it's taking a like a's and
b's and
then there's another half adder and the
third thing is it's combining the
carry out using an or and
we can see that the sum is actually we
can see that the only thing it really
needs is an additional in
which is to carry in and we also see
that it combines carry
carry it combines to carry the carries
with
with this ore operator now the reason
why i had a
a half adder now i'm showing a full
adder is because i want to
show like
how one might analyze this very simple
elementary circuit so if i made a if i
took a box
and i just drew like a a boundary
around the original half adder
i can analyze that and i can say hey
this half adder works this way
if i take away that boundary i can say
hey this half adder works this way
you know there's no just because of the
context that the half adder is in
doesn't change the meaning of what it is
to be a half adder
and i can tell you that not all
programming languages work that way
and i can tell you the majority of them
don't sometimes i can stick
in to keep with the analogy i'll stick a
half adder in a new context like a full
adder
and it would change the definition of a
half adder now when that happens it does
not have a property and we call that
property referential transparency
and it's very very important why is it
important because
if i test the half adder and i put two
half adders together
i could almost guarantee you that
they'll work in a certain way
so basically my testing burden actually
goes way way down
because i have guarantees that are not
available to me in other programming
languages
so when you use a purely functional
approach you get this
you get certain guarantees that speed
development
and so while it may take a little bit a
little bit uh extra time to actually get
comfortable with these
these uh the these these principles
it actually saves you a lot of time
because you don't have to
you'll find yourself not testing as much
not because you don't have to it's just
that there's less to test
one test is like three tests you know
the power of one test in a haskell
program
or a functional program is about is
equivalent to about four or five in
another program
which means that you have to maintain
less which means that you know your
benefit
of speed is actually you know
quadrupling and multiplying
uh you know scaling exponentially so
let's go ahead and see if uh you know
the properties of this circuit actually
map to to um to uh
you know our
our actual program here
so what i want to do is i actually want
to make a full adder
now foot a full adder actually takes
oh let's see i don't want to cheat here
let's say it takes three bits
okay it takes three bits
and it returns just like the other one a
pair of bits
all right we got a full adder and a full
adder initially
equals undefined
okay so i wrote the definition of our
full adder and our definition of our
full adder is free of syntax errors
that's actually quite quick
all right so what i need for my three
inputs is going to be you know the input
one
input two and the carry in bit
so i'm going to say input
one i don't know why that completed
input two and i'm gonna call this one
carry
in with no capital
of course
all right so based on our specification
we can just see what it does
so our a and b actually do exactly what
they're supposed to a and b are supposed
to go
into uh pretty much get fed into our
half adder
so let's see
let's see
let's look at this from a higher level
actually
okay let's see
cool so what i just said is that okay
we're gonna need the input from one
uh half adder we're gonna say half adder
we're going to say that uh the half
added the first
the the output of the first
half adder is pretty much represented
by this thing okay
and the input of the second half adder
is the output of the first half adder
and the carrying
so forgive me
i'm gonna screw that up
all right
what i want is my son
to b so right now i could actually
calculate my sum
because my sum is the output of the
second uh half adder and carry in
so basically what i can do is i can say
my sum
is simply
or i can just say x
um
yeah so i'm actually uh pulling out the
sum here
and that's going to be like our sum
or our pair i can't like let's see if i
can shrink this down a little bit
all right so our sum is going to be the
output of
the the first half adder uh
with our the sum of the first half adder
with our
our carry in so and that's going to be
xor
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
xor that
with uh with our
carry in
and i'm going to say
that or carry in
so
so i think what i'm going to say is that
i'm going to actually okay so we can see
that the
input to our our second half adder is
actually
the the output of the sum of the first
half adder
and the and the carry in so that's going
to be the input
to our second half adder and i think
i can take the the two carryouts of the
half adders
and uh and just or them together and
that would be
my uh my result so
what i can do is get the sum i could
just put another
let me see some
output
prime and i can say carry
output prime
and i can say that this equals a half
adder
excuse me
this equals the half adder of the sum
output
the original sum output and
my carry in
oops i don't want to tuple that up
all right and
what i can say is my final result is
simply uh the sum output prime
and i can see that the carry out for my
final result
is going to be the or
of my two carry outputs carry output
and carry output prime
all right
um
all right let's see uh what we got here
compilation failed why
okay so there's no such thing as a
okay this isn't gonna change it i just
okay so i can't match bit the two bits
with the expected type bool
i was actually a little confused because
i didn't see it pop up in red
now that's the the problem is that
there's we're getting the wrong
error for the same reason uh as we did
before so or is actually defined in
prelude and we want to take that away
so we hid that from from being exported
by
uh prelude now it's telling us
at this point would be then why are you
not using preludes or
because in a sense you want to
fundamentally redefine
a library function okay so
uh preludes or works on booleans
and our domain is is bit
and high and low so we can't reuse that
because
oh if we did if we reused it we'd have
to do some translation and
we'd probably end up getting the same
thing that's why i'm getting an error
all right so
that's a very good
that's a very good question so uh i
actually kind of
wrestle with that myself i understand
that that prime
is it's kind of well known
as like you know i'm the same thing but
i'm different yeah yeah assume that so
that's right so one of the things i mean
the reason why i think that's a good
question is because one of the reasons
uh one of the things that i do in
addition to programming in in
an attempt to write better programs and
more readable programs is i try to find
out what the definition of readability
is for spoken languages
and one of the one of the requirements
for readability is what the person
actually brings to the table when they
start reading the text
so if a mathematician sits down he may
find a mathematical
text very readable because he's used to
all those terms and everything
but if another person sits down they're
not really going to be used to
all that stuff so the the text may be
simple in all other cases
except for what they they bring to the
table and that's called
that's a form of redundancy the
redundancy
is that the what the paper is presenting
you already know
so that's a redundant information uh in
the literature
so in this case i was assuming that most
people would be familiar with prime
because i'm sitting in exchange
absolutely so it appears it appears that
i've been like
i've been my request has been vetoed
by by the crowd so i'm going to change
this so i'm going to say uh
i'll put two no that's a that's an
awesome crowd actually
so uh this is the sum output okay i want
the sum output one and i want to carry
output
one and i want to carry output two uh so
i guess i'm gonna have to change where
the carry output
comes from
and actually i think there's a there
might be a uh
no that's okay um
all right so
some output
to the carry output
uh two
and i took the carry output and i
ordered with this area output two
and i said that's
what i want to some output two right i
want the sum output two
uh does that actually let's uh
make our over back on track and make our
or
just is a function of two bits
uh let's say or and i will say
uh an or means that if any one of them
is high
then it's high so basically i can just
define the case where they're both low
and
say that that's going to be low and i
can say all other cases
alright
all the cases would result in high
so it looks like
looks like everyone is happy now
so let's go over a couple of things that
we've done really quick before we verify
that it's like
you know everything's cool uh
so as you can see i used uh
destructuring here down on line 27 and
line 28
to define my my two the inputs to my two
half adders
and i've done some pattern matching but
we've seen all of that before
but we uh now we've fully defined our
full adder
so i'm actually going to go ahead and uh
and test to see if my full adder
is working i am if this thing
actually works i'd be surprised
so so uh
i think i followed uh the schematic kite
kind of nicely
let's let's go see uh what's going on
here so
um if i say full add
if i save my full adder and i give it
let's say for instance give it all those
because that's something i know is uh
what it should be and i get low
okay that that makes sense uh for my
full adder if i
add up you know three uh
if i add up uh three bits that are all
low they should be low
if i out of three bits that should that
are where
one of them is actually high then
i should receive you know for the
carryout
i should receive a sum of one and the
carryout should be low
so that's what i'm actually expecting
well i kind of got that
if i if i have all high well the only
way that i can get uh both
all highs or the only way i can get a
binary three is if i have all highs
so let's see if the that that case works
so i get high high
okay so uh i just kind of threw together
a program here
of the full adder following this
schematic and i was talking in the same
language that the schematic is actually
communicating to me
and it looks like i have a a working a
working program
when someone actually comes in and looks
at this program
let's say that that person is actually
you know familiar with
uh let's say the person is actually very
familiar with the domain but has never
looked at the code before
i don't think it would be too much of a
stretch for him to go uh
and obviously this is really like a
really simple case
but i don't think using these domain
terms and and so forth
i don't think it'll be too much of a
stretch for him to sit down and actually
understand what's going on in the
program
and that's what we're trying to to do
here that's actually what we're trying
to provide and that's what i think
haskell is actually providing us
and i think that's one of the biggest
benefits of haskell
now when we go to haskell when we look
at haskell and we see things like
okay these are monads and we look at
haskell and we say we see things like
you know these are are applicative
functions and these are bi-functors and
these are pro-functors
the reason why we get away with that is
because mathematicians
who can sit down and encode this stuff
almost verbatim from the text that
they're reading
and because it's so easy to do that some
of these beneficial concepts actually
make their way into the language
so you might also be mentioning that
that these kind of string diagrams like
you have of the logic are actually
very close to that mathematics indeed
yes not to
digress but um when i've
hidden my prelude import and an ore
um i'm coming up with an error that n is
undefined
so where was it in you had to find it ah
i i defined it up here
oh uh one line 19. yeah thanks
not a problem cool
all right so uh as you can see you can
easily go from your domain terms to
to uh to a haskell program uh
and i don't wanna
digress either but you can actually
start to see
patterns like because it's so i mean i i
i'd venture to say it's pretty clear and
because it's so clear you can actually
see
abstract patterns now what do i mean by
abstract patterns
i can see that what i'm doing in this uh
in this this diagram is i'm actually
taking a signal and splitting that
signal
but i can't really represent that in my
program i'm actually taking
you know uh signals and combining them
now what if i wanted that abstractness
what if i wanted the the idea of taking
signals being able to combine them
taking uh uh you know signals and being
able to split them
and doing like stuff like that that that
that
it in itself is an abstract concept and
it's one of the
it's one thing in haskell that some
people have have a trouble
uh conquering at first but that abstract
model of computation is known as arrows
the idea to like manipulate things in
that sort of fashion
so if you ever run across arrows that is
the that is taking what we just did and
abstracting it down
a little bit so that and giving us like
a mechanism to rebuild
this so i can take this whole program
and and re-implement it in terms of
arrows
because that's an abstraction that we
can use to to uh
to model signals and splitting them and
so forth so as you can see some of these
things like if i come across
arrows i might say you know what what am
i going to do with this
this is an abstraction that was pulled
out of a pattern that that is much like
much like what we're doing here so
um sure
yes sir now if you reverse those two
lines under where would this will work
right here
yeah okay so
so basically the order of the
definitions doesn't actually doesn't
actually matter because this is a pure
function
now if i was inside of monad where the
order of the definitions actually
do matter and a lot of times uh one of
the reasons why you will be in a monad
is because the order of the definitions
do matter
but uh just like in mathematics the
order of things don't actually
the order that things take are are kind
of presented and don't really make
make much of a difference of course
order of operation sticks uh
means a lot of things but the order in
which things appear don't actually
make much of a difference yes sir
so are these uh definitions and where
mods
playfully evaluated so that if you
declare something that you're not
actually using it doesn't actually
increase your complications or is it
lazy evaluation only occurring in
another context
so most things in haskell are lazily
evaluated
values aren't actually evaluated until
they're they're they're needed
and um i guess i could i could i could
i guess a good exercise uh how much time
do i have them
all right so i could actually uh show
this and give you a good way to uh
to to find out whether something's
lazily evaluated or not
and it's really not that hard one thing
that you probably want to do is you um
let me see uh
let's uh expand this for a second and
let's put in a question mark and if you
look
what uh um
you know haskell gives you it gives you
the ability to
um you know set a break point so you can
set a breakpoint in there
some people think that haskell doesn't
have a debugger and i think that haskell
doesn't
actually have a debugger but it has
something like a debugger that can be
used as a debugger
so we're going to actually set a break
point and i'm going to set that break
point
on um on let's see somewhere we can get
some kind of information so i'm going to
set that break point on line
20 yeah let's just set it on line 25
so i can say according to the you know
whatever the thing is we have here
i think we just break right so i can
just say
break on line 25
and what does it say it says oh i set a
breakpoint on line 25. so if i try to
execute line 25
which is uh what was line 25 our full
adder
so let's go ahead and full add something
that's flat eye so i actually broke on
on uh line 25 actually broke on
line 25 uh four to 51. so as you can see
i have all these
these variables i have the carry out i
have the carry output two and i have the
sum output
but what is the value of these things
the value of them
is unknown because we haven't used them
yet and and so they're
they're unevaluated which is the
definition of laziness right
so how do i actually look at this stuff
uh
i could actually force you know some
output
too so i'm going to force it i'm going
to say i'm going to evaluate you because
i really want to know what you are
well now we know it's high because i
forced it otherwise it's unevaluated
so uh there there's like the the
evidence that we're actually
kind of lazy and that's the evidence
that you use uh that's the way you use
to show other people evident
all right so let's carry on with the um
and if you're in if you're in the mood
to make things strict you can use bang
patterns right
so i can just like put these bangs in
here and it tells haskell
evaluate it immediately and this way
when i ran when i run my little uh
debugger you can see that
they would all have their values
immediately
so i guess let's uh let's try to
like drive to the end of this uh this
this presentation here i forgot where it
actually is
oh it's like over here somewhere okay so
what advantages have we seen because we
went through this whole exercise let's
talk about the advantages
so we have the imperative things like
ruby c plus plus vb
python and java not that there's
anything wrong with these languages but
if you're going to actually present a
new paradigm that people have to learn
there better be some advantages you know
so i thought that was actually kind of
easy
you know it's pure simple and fun that's
one advantage
i actually thought that the guarantees
of pure like the
guarantees of purity actually helped me
like i actually just typed in this
program straight off head
like i didn't develop that earlier in
the day or anything i just did it i just
did it right now
with audience feedback thank you very
much in it yeah
definitely please would i have saved
a ton of time by just using a new
type
for bit saving all that
what do you mean like so evie's like uh
one of the things that evie would have
liked to do is she would either you like
to use a type alias
so if he's like you know i'm just going
to type alias bull and i'll get
i get to use re i get to reuse all of my
cool functions
and i uh and i get to uh to use the
things that are already
defined also she set a new type so a new
type is a little bit uh
stronger and the compiler actually goes
down to the
the the the underlying type so it's a
it's a
a new type is really like a uh an
optimization
technique uh maybe
maybe and the reason why is because like
as you can saw how did you see how end
was implemented yeah
so n was implemented as i take a list of
things right
so you might be like uh maybe i need
something like n but then you'd find
something else like the amp the two
ampersands and stuff
so in this case maybe you would you you
might have saved some time
uh how much time you would have saved
you wouldn't have to define
end or xor so you wouldn't have to find
they'll find three functions
which was the ball which was you know
the nylon
yeah so it was about nine lines how much
time maybe you would have saved some
time but the point is
we want it to be uh we wanted to work in
our high level domain terms
and that would have still enabled that
but you're also
able to show us the dsl in action
absolutely
thank you
okay so the manipulation of high level
terms with low ceremony and feedback on
the level
so what i mean by feedback on the level
is when the compiler came back or the
type checker came back
uh and told me there was something wrong
it was telling me that there was
something wrong
in the language i was talking about it
was like hey there's no such thing as an
xor it wasn't like kind of saying you
know
uh this object was supposed to not be
null and now it's known
it's actually telling us like you know
xor
so that all goes back to our
communication and verification we're
communicating
you know in the past we would just
compile uh we would write program
compile the com
the program would actually come back and
say hey nothing's working
please fix now we're actually have this
little intermediate program that's
checking things and giving us back
information very very quickly
now that's a rapid feedback loop that's
what we wanted that's what our
our ooda loop is all about and so
because we can do all that we want to
say things like uh we want to ask this
question we want to ask the questions do
the languages we speak shape the way we
think
do they merely express thought or do
they or do the structures in the
language
with or without our knowledge shape the
thoughts that we wish to express
now is that is that true now i i say
that is true
and the reason why that i say that is
true is because um
well i only speak one spoken language i
mean how many people here speak
multiple languages uh so is
is that like actually a true thing or do
you do you actually
uh totally like when i'm in germany
is such a logical and methodical
language
and you basically uh when i was learning
german i was
in class with like these 18 year old
korean girls because they were learning
music
and they were they just knew math very
well
they don't speak me in german
because of just the math they just know
all the grammatical rules
and that can matter oh wow and they were
able to just do that very fast
so like definitely like german is very
like
logical precise to like to death
yeah when you want to add new words
there's actually words working real life
little words
in german which are longer than 26
letters well they have a habit of
smushing words together that's just
because they don't like spaces
i mean the the the most linguistically
informed answer is
languages let me just constrain what you
must say but not what you may say
anything expressible one language is
expressible in another if it has the
right vocabulary
but it's certain i mean if you're
talking in english it's impossible
not to not to be deciding all the time
am i singular
am i talking about one thing or many
things there's a singular plural
english forces you into that chinese
does it uh
as a just as a simple example there's a
there's so in general it's about how
does the language
how does the language compel you to
express certain things rather than
you know does
yeah when it comes back to the concept
to a conservation of energy
what is easy to express will be
expressed more so than what we
disciplined to express
yeah cool all right so
there's a trade-off because they're both
listeners and speakers
speakers would do best if everything was
implicit but listeners don't do too well
when everything is implicit
all right so let me see let me uh let me
drive
so i this comes from a a
a blog post that was that was uh not a
blog post but an article from the wall
street journal i just mixed up the jne
evie was able to put that together it's
usually called the superior horror
hypothesis yeah i'm saying well there's
a w and an s
in there i don't know where the j came
from okay
yeah so let me let me drive because i'm
dyslexic and they reverse them
thank you thanks for sharing all right
so uh
let me drive to the end of this uh this
presentation really quick so
uh i think the the answer is yes and i'm
glad people kind of verify that with me
because
uh once you get into this functional
state of mind you start to like
want to do things functionally so
there's tools out there
like nyx os and darks nyx os is an
operating system whose configuration and
package management
is purely functional darts is a is is
pretty much a git but with a
theory of patches that's very functional
in nature and gives you some of the same
benefits as function
as functional things however sometimes
we have to compromise
because nixos while it has this great
package manager it's not really the
greatest
you know linux distribution on earth and
darks while it has this very nice uh
you know theory of patches unless you do
all these wonderful things
uh it's really you know cannot compete
with some tools like
you know docker and git
so you know sometimes pragmatics
actually beats out theria
a great deal um so
i i would like to say that
i think mixos can beat out docker
okay
okay so uh docker does have event
but i definitely think that there's a
place to vote
all right so yes uh so uh ryan is is uh
you know if if we don't if no one knows
ryan ryan is uh
the cto of a company called sked me and
he's been doing haskell development for
quite some time
and yeah i'm aware that uh i'm aware
that he uses nixos i just wasn't aware
that he was standing here so
right so again like we're back with uh
with language and i say one of the
things that haskell does well
is dsls pascal also as you you saw in
our
you know our mini uh programming
exercise that we were able to
express and build our languages our
language incrementally
so with concepts of like domain-driven
design and ubiquitous language and stuff
haskell really really applies itself in
that that uh that domain
so i guess uh you know when we go back
to the point
you know what we're looking for is
techniques to to control the
intellectual complexity of
large software systems and i really do
believe that haskell gives us that
and again it's just communication and
verification so
i was going to move into another
exercise but i think that we're out of
time so i'm just going to leave that one
uh
leave that one alone i was going to move
into like how you uh you know how to
to make a haskell uh make a quick like
skeleton haskell app from
from uh continuous integration all the
way down like in a very like
uh systematic approach because there's
people out there who don't think that
haskell has the support for these tools
that they might get in in other
languages but you know
you know after writing like some
production haskell apps and we needed
these things i reached for them and they
were there
and if they weren't there we were able
to get it to work so i guess that uh
i'll wrap up
there because i don't have much time and
i'll i'll leave
the remainder of time for for questions
okay so esco offers a
if you program haskell in a certain way
because you can clearly program and
haskell in a very uh
untyped safe way you can do things that
you know the language doesn't really
encourage and the community doesn't
encourage
but if you program haskell in uh in a
certain way you'll get certain
guarantees
and those guarantees really pay off one
of the haskell applications that we're
working on right now is a
uh oil filled monitoring system so
that's like
you know you don't want things to
explode or you don't want gauges to give
wrong
readings and you don't want these things
to to take place
and where that whole application is in
is in haskell like it's just 100 haskell
um and so these are kind of things that
you might want to use haskell for
and but they're not the only things that
you want to use haskell for
if you want to to move quickly
if you just want to move quickly in
general while building an application
it's a good idea to use haskell and the
reason why i say that it's a good idea
a good idea to use haskell or something
like it is for a lot of the reasons i
was pointing out
like for instance good programming
practice dictates that you might have
a ubiquitous language it is very easy to
encode that ubiquitous language
in haskell for the same reasons that
people make dsls in haskell
so these are some of the reasons why i
choose haskell over
over some languages uh there are other
languages out there that have a lot of
the same benefits as haskell and you're
free to use those
but my choice is haskell so is it true
that has school programmers get paid
less than java
problem will work because you have to
broaden the job of partners into doing
it
yes
but for how long so how
so there are tools like a quick check
for example that can help you
check the correctness of your your
program through generative testing
how applicable are tools like quick
check to
such a large application like this oil
field management system
oh i mean quick check is just i mean
quick check just
just works it's awesome uh uh let me see
there's one of the examples that i've
seen have been
mathematical i guess and so what you're
what you're just trying to
so quick check is actually two things
and i think that the second thing it is
doesn't get enough attention
so quick check is property-based testing
but if you're testing on concrete values
then how could you test the properties
so quick quick check actually has to
have a a data generator a data generator
generation language now there are other
data generation languages
i wouldn't say languages but kind of
tools and one of those tools is famous
from the ruby community it's called
factory girl
now quick check is like super factory
girl
quick check you have so much control
over the random data that you're
generating
you know sometimes i i wish i could just
like uh send emails to the
the maintainers of large packages and
say hey can you just would it be too
much to ask if you just provide quick
check instances for all your data
because i'm going to use them so uh one
thing i can do with quickjack is i can
you know randomly generate data now i'll
tell you one place where i actually use
that
when you uh in the the uh one of the
projects of course is the oil field
thing and one thing you can you can do
is take all your your readings like from
your
you know your 10 gauge reading and your
angular gauge reading and all of that
and you can export
uh excel spreadsheets you can export
excel
versions of that that spreadsheet when i
was testing that
uh because i didn't want to test that
because it was doing some complex
transformations on data
i was actually able to just use quick
check to to generate a lot of that data
now i wasn't even using the property so
i wasn't even verifying properties i was
just generating that data so that i can
populate
a selenium test so quick check actually
does come with
with a with a quick check is useful
outside of just running properties
however your your question was really
like when do i get to use these
properties or when should i use these
properties
if you're uh if you can come up with a
property for one of your functions
then you can use quick check for
instance um
if i'm writing something simple like uh
um
you know for instance like this this
just adder
thing i can i could probably come up
with a few like
uh like fundamental properties that i
can test with quick check
when i was at strange loop not too long
ago somebody came up to me and said hey
i heard you know haskell can you help me
you know write a fizz buzz program we
came up with about eight properties
simply for fizzbuzz
we were like okay fizzbuzz should do
this and the fizzbuzz does not have this
property then it doesn't work
so you can pretty much come up with
these arbitrary properties that seem to
to uh to really like make sense
you can say that if my my system or my
function does uh
if i give my my function like anything
above 12
and i give my function anything below
you know below 12 then it should have
this behavior
so you make up two random generators one
that generates everything above 12 and
one that
generates things below 12 and you just
run quick check over it and it gives you
the
i mean that's a legitimate property and
if it gives you uh the right output for
100 test cases
then you're like okay i have some kind
of assurance that this is working
it does work better when you actually
have concrete properties that were
proven somewhere and so forth and so on
but i i find quick check a very valuable
tool
uh using quick check over properties is
great
um when you if you think about what
you're doing when you run an assertion
and you take one value
you're taking one point in space of
usually an infinite
domain and you're kind of like saying
you know because this one
one point works then everything works if
you think about if you think about it
that way it seems actually kind of
absurd
really like if i say one plus one my
plus function one plus one gives me back
two
so therefore i'm going to assume that my
my addition
function is actually well you're also
using the fact of a random sample
yeah but it's not very good so
i mean that that's just that's just my
my take on it um
so that's what i got uh i see there's a
question
back here um unless anyone else wants to
scan this topic
uh i was curious about
the line you added in order to display
to print the values of the
deriving the show uh one thing i'm
curious about with
um like lisps for instance is the
separation of the
logic and how in practice you use that
to
actually add new functionality to
existing types
um things like that in a way where you
don't
have to have like secret knowledge that
oh
if you need to and some bits you have to
go to this
particular module all right so i think
what you're touching on is called the
expression problem
yes and uh the expression problem is
is sort of kind of like this okay so
you're
you're either gonna have the ability to
extend your types
without changing your without uh having
to make a change to existing code
but you're you're going to have to ex
you can extend your your functionality
without having to make a change to an
existing code
ryan or evie if you know this better
than i do can you please
like help yeah i
actually had a smile when i said uh
years ago
i would say that the first thing when
dealing with these question problems
is to realize that it's not going to be
tractable there's not going to be a
silver bullet
sometimes you actually have to write n
squared
and once you realize that the question
becomes or
let me say big o and square code not
necessarily
you know every single thing but you know
so
for example we have security policies
now
we sort of boiled that down to a very
small version
of what it is we don't have permission
systems
like that what we have is a notion of
roles
and a notion of actions and
fundamentally what a security system
does is looks at someone's role
and determines whether they can perform
given action
and i think there's an inherent
n-squared nature to that at the end of
the day you could have some
manager come in from your client and
just fill in
arbitrary dots on that matrix and just
say
this guy can do this so
you can't really get away from the fact
that events work but what you can do
is you can take this grid and you can be
very disciplined about filling it in
and that's what haskell helps with so
when you have case statements
you can have functions that take you
know delegate from one side of the grid
to the other
you can sort of take this grid and carve
our column out and say
well admins can always do everything
okay that's you know super user is super
user done
um you know then once you carve off that
column well you still have this whole
other grid
but that column is good and so
at scheduling we use type classes for
this particular situation
that lets us have a sort of open
system for filling in this grid but it's
still checked by the compiler
so if we missed something uh everything
will be syntactically valid
but it'll fail compilations we won't be
able to look up the right type quest
instance but we've had a lot of success
with
first embracing the fact that sometimes
you actually have a lot of code to go
right
and then using the tools available
to make sure that you don't miss things
and sometimes it means to have some
language for this
my employer for example uses prolog for
this purpose because yeah perfect
yeah you write down some prologue rules
when the right thing happens
exactly exactly and prolong does a lot
of stuff it's
like instance resolution yeah the way
that prologue does its search algorithms
have a lot of stuff in common exactly
and so you know at the end of the day
you want to make sure that you cover
each square exactly once and and that's
the important part
prolog helps you do that instance
resolution
just being disciplined about your case
statements uh your case expressions and
hassle
that can also do it but the important
thing is to know
at compile time that you're done
absolutely thank you ryan so i guess uh
we're a little bit over time so i guess
i'll just wrap it up here and if you
have any additional questions
i can ask you can add i'll try to answer
them after afterward
thank you